gamespot has been headquartered at
various spots around San Francisco since
its inception back in 1996 but during
that time hundreds of people have walked
in and walked out of its many doors a
website is nothing without the people
behind it so today I'm gonna step away
from the games and focus this video on
some of the people who made GameSpot
what it is over the past two decades the
people who wrote the reviews edited the
videos and built the website the people
who inspired people like me to get
involved in this line of work
and apologies in advance to everyone who
I leave out your endeavours are greatly
appreciated but this video can only be
so long I want to start off with the guy
who made me want to do this work in the
first place rich Gallup started a
GameSpot as an intern for the live team
that eventually became the host and
producer of the site's seminal live show
on the spot he and his mysterious gray
eyebrow were the face of the site for
nearly half a decade hosting several of
game spots III live shows he eventually
left the site in August of 2007 moved to
the East Coast and joined Curt
Schilling's 38 studios as lead producer
the developers of Kingdoms of Amalur
reckoning and the unreleased MMO
codenamed project Calpurnia's would
eventually go bankrupt when a loan
guarantee from the state of Rhode Island
would turn sour but rich bounced back
landing a job at disruptor beam where he
now works as AP of a bunch of games
including Star Trek timelines and Game
of Thrones ascent if you miss him you
can catch his infrequent appearances on
our sister site giant pop speaking of
which time bomb Kampf ended by Jeff
Gerstmann and Ryan Davis was staffed by
a large number of former GameSpot
employees including Vinnie Caravela Brad
shoemaker and alex navaro all of whom
can still be found on the site but
before Jeff's controversial termination
in 2007 he had spent 11 years at
GameSpot eventually rising to the role
of editorial director during that time
he himself published over 1000 reviews
and became one of the leading voices in
the industry
he found a Giant Bomb with Ryan Davis an
equally prolific reviewer who's cutting
humor became a staple of GameSpot's
video productions during his tenure upon
leaving Ryan would become host of the
Giant Bomb cast one of the most popular
gaming podcasts in the world as you
probably know Ryan tragically passed
away in July of 2013 for the Testaments
to his enduring popularity was how the
online gaming community reacted his life
was celebrated in meetups attended by
fans all
and the world perhaps as prolific as
Jeff was Justin Calvert who spent 14
years at GameSpot both in our London
office and San Francisco eventually
becoming editor-in-chief he left the
site in August of 2014 and became senior
management of content services for the
US wing of World of Tanks creator
wargaming but he left them earlier this
year and has just moved said Los Angeles
to work for Blizzard Entertainment
Sophia Tong was editor at GameSpot for
three and a half years before she left
in 2011 since then she became the editor
in chief of games radar then the global
editor-in-chief for all of future us and
she just recently joined twitch as
publisher and developer relations
manager in fact the fast expanding
twitch has become the home of a number
of ex GameSpot employees in recent
months Shaw McInnis wrote previews
reviews and hosted videos for over seven
years before leaving in 2014 and he
recently joined twitch as publisher and
developer relations manager Josh Shaw
and Dan mejor ik responsible for keeping
all of our awesome live streams up and
running over the past couple of years
now helped produce twitches in Hef's
live stream content but let's leave the
Bay Area for a moment and check in on
some of our international friends my
good buddy Johnny Kia Dini host of
feedback EULA and a half dozen other
productions out of the gates by UK
office is now creating wonderful work
over at Eurogamer Marc Walton left
GameSpot after five years of excellent
writing to join ARS technica UK where
you can still find him today
Jane Douglas has since founded the
tremendously successful YouTube channel
outside Xbox partners in crime Cameron
Robinson and Seb Ford have their very
own YouTube channel too but they also
founded the successful video production
company double-jump my old flatmate Marc
and Gaston the smartest person I've ever
worked with was news editor GameSpot for
a year and a half he eventually became
the social marketing manager for EMEA
but has since left that job and is
considering a new direction selfishly
I'm hoping he gets back to writing since
we're flying we might as well check in
on our Australian colleagues don.t apini
was an editor at GameSpot au for over
six and a half years he's now PR manager
for the one and only Blizzard
Entertainment prior to landing a job as
associate editor at our Sydney offices
Laura Parker worked as a news reporter
for the Sydney Morning Herald
she left GameSpot after five years to
move to New York where she now works as
a contributing writer for the New York
Times and a commissioning editor for The
Guardian as a freelance writer she's
also contributed to publications in
The New Yorker Vanity Fair on Rolling
Stone and on table Avadh she's currently
writing a nonfiction book about
videogames and positive social change
it'll be published by Macmillan in
January of next year as a fan of this
site for years before I worked here it
will be impossible for me not to mention
Jodie Robinson
GameSpot's community manager and the
bedrock that the GameSpot community for
almost a decade she now works as
community program specialist for League
of Legends creator Riot Games Greg
Kasavin was the EIC of the site once he
departed his decade-long tenured
GameSpot back in January of 2007 he
subsequently worked at EA as a producer
helping shift command & Conquer Red
Alert 3 he then worked at Jaeger and
helped the market the wonderful SpecOps
the line but today he makes his very own
games as creative director of supergiant
games he helped design and write the
wonderful Bastion and transistor
supergiant are currently working on
their third game hire Tyler wine Gardner
worked as a producer and editor on
GameSpot for years working on such
projects as lost between levels he now
shoots incredible work as video producer
for Make Magazine my dear friend Andy
Bauman who I consider the best cameraman
the slide ever had left GameSpot earlier
this year and networks just down the
road at Ubisoft alongside the prolific
former GameSpot editor at large
Giancarlo very nene mark anderson worked
at the site for almost ten years before
leaving earlier this month he's on
vacation in Europe right now awaiting
his next adventure
Bryan Ekberg Roden hosted shows for six
years before joining Microsoft as a
community manager mostly working on the
fort's of franchise his co-hosts on the
lineup Aaron Thomas now works as a
Content specialist for Sony
former VP of programming and teenage
games master contributor John Davison
has recently launched Flixel a new video
game website the publisher of Rolling
Stone Carrie couscous was feature editor
on gamespot back in the mid-2000s
she's since had a rich career in games
development she worked as a designer and
producer at mythic and has almost into
her seventh year working at EA she
currently works as leaf producer of
their incredibly popular mobile game The
Simpsons top - like myself Kevin Van
Horn and Carolyn Pettis arose from the
GameSpot community Carolyn wrote
incredible reviews and lent her brave
and unique voice to GameSpot for almost
four years she now works alongside Anita
sarkeesian at feminist frequency
Kevin Van Award worked at GameSpot for
eight years starting out as a tournament
court
and eventually rising two reviews editor
he published over 700 reviews during his
time at the site but now lends his
writing talents to video games he worked
as English editor for MMO developer
Trion Worlds and has recently taken up a
job at Lowry and studios where he'll be
helping to write a sequel to divinity
original sin this also means he's moving
to Belgium in a few months
enjoy the waffles Kevin San Francisco
will miss you in fact we miss a lot of
our old colleagues the countless number
of folks who kept our videos looking
great and the site staying of people
like Benito Gonzales joy Talent Werner
golf Alexis Ganesha Ryan McDonald who
ran GameSpot's video for an incredible
18 and a half years who figured out how
to livestream video games a decade
before it made any money who produced
dozens of timeless shows he now runs his
own production company and tries to save
the world a little bit with help
worldwide and then there's the
incredible Homer Homer camera bara who
put a smile on GameSpot viewers faces
for over 6 years he spent some time at
Sony and Networks making videos pop on
the other side of the bay at 2k games
Brendan Sinclair wrote thousands of news
articles and hosted the hot spot during
his seven-year tour at GameSpot he since
moved back to his native Canada where he
works as a senior editor at games
industry buff is you can catch him with
Carolyn Pettis and form a reviewer Tom
McShea
who wrote for the site for six years on
their new podcast the crockpot these are
just a small handful of the dozens of
people who have left their mark on
GameSpot over the past two decades
people who love games at their time
against button for the most part
continue to find work in games after
they left the site so on behalf of
GameSpot and as a longtime fan of this
site I want to thank them and everybody
I failed to mention for contributing to
the wonderful grand old story of
GameSpot and also thanks to you for
watching reading and commenting on all
of our work over the past two decades
here's to two more